good friend of the show longtime friend
Shawn Salisbury and show the debut Super
Bowl week on SP nation radio and ESPN
radio host here in Houston
good to see you Shawn good to see you
bud all right good if you had question a
question asked to Brady this week what
would you ask Brady what are you curious
about IIIi think for me it would be does
he care about the legacy of being the
goat and number one number two is Dan
and I believe in my mind that if he wins
this game you know how we talk about
every single we talk about Lawrence
Taylor and we there's maybe three or
four linebackers we might compare to him
Anthony Munoz three or four linemen I'm
about the best of all time we talked
about corners or safeties when we talk
about wide receiver what name comes to
your mind Jerry Rice and nobody else
correct you know I think we're at the
point it's no longer a conversation for
me is that Tom or is a Joe Montana to me
Tom Brady is the goat because he's done
more with less than any player at that
position we've ever had different guy
how many Hall of Famers are gonna be
offensive player that have played on the
offense he's ever played with one Randy
Moss and maybe Gronkowski if this
continues so if he wins this game done
more with less than any quarterback ever
he's playing better now than he did ten
years ago mechanics he even held Tom we
used to be able to back pedal faster
than him he actually can make some
things happen and slide step and still
make things go and in that pocket nobody
better Dana I'm no longer just talking
about is he the best quarterback of all
time he wins this what I'd ask Tom is do
you think you're the best football
player we've ever had what if he loses
this game the questions are gonna be
well Joe went to three was the MV or
four was the MVP and three never lost
doesn't throw the ball the other team
ever in those games that winning
percentage is perfect Tom why did you
lose three and then the response for me
would be Tom got to seven and I hey by
no mean I thought Joe Montana with John
I mean Dan we know how special he is we
do but were you in the NFL when my yes I
was I was why I mean I was in that era
of Kelly and Marino and Elway and young
and Montana that's pretty good ones
there's five Hall of Famers right there
and far of that group but to watch
if he doesn't win this game that's
winning for losing three ben27 it's kind
of like the Michael Jordan LeBron James
talk but getting to 7 Dan come on member
Oh Marino went to one we thought he
thought he'd get back to five more yeah
it's so hard to get back but I I am a to
me it won't tarnish his legacy it just
says he took teams that shouldn't have
been there and got him there but to get
to seven now you're talking about he's
one more away from being winning for
losing for because I don't believe he's
done getting to him even after this year
I think there's more in his future but
it will not tarnish his legacy to lose
this all's that can do in my - to
enhance it and take him to a level that
says now he's in the Jerry Rice category
Jim Brown categories the best we've ever
seen period I also look at the situation
with the Patriots getting here without
Gronkowski and wondering where they go
in the future with out gruncle ski right
I don't know what kind of trade value he
would have if you just because Belichick
always gets rid of you before it's too
late
never missed out on that ever yes now
can you seem like in and it feels like
he's you know but staple in the family
there could you see a situation where
Belichick would entertain trade talks
for Gronkowski yes can't you I can
because I think he's been in
consistently great Patriots yes and
think about Dan there's no sacred cows
in New England oh there's one
Brady and he happens to be the
quarterback but we even heard we even
heard the talk this year when Garoppolo
was playing and just threw six quarters
of football huh maybe it's time for
Tammy to go you got to get out of that
Dave would ever entertain an idea to get
rid of Brady absolutely not Garoppolo
will be playing for somebody else in
2017 and Tom Brady will still be the
quarterback and still be as good as we
have in a league when he turns 40 what
during next football season so do I
think with Gronkowski and Dan remember
when he went out we all thought oh
what's gonna happen now that missed a
beat they have not missed a beat
nobody does more with less he takes guys
like me and you in the slot or tied it
well maybe not me but because you're
athletic
of course and he'll catch you'll catch
Hogan's now a superstar he's a star in
this league yeah and so I
I can foresee it because I can foresee a
Texans team without JJ Watt you can go
to in 14 with the greatest defensive
player in the league if Tom Brady goes
to Cleveland or Aaron Rodgers goes to
San Francisco their minimum of a 500
team this past year that's the
difference if a guy like JJ water
Gronkowski goes to Cleveland or San
Francisco as great as they are they can
still go three and 13 so the value on
the quarterback as opposed to somewhere
else and Tom they'll find somebody else
but I don't think they want to move
Gronkowski the key is how much healthier
I mean how does this keep having in nine
games ten yeah he's such a special
player Gronk is but as he's part of the
family but he can be a family somewhere
else too could you see a situation where
JJ watched not with the Texan yes let me
ask you this if by the way we're talking
to Shawn Solsbury if say somebody called
up and said a team that needs a quarter
bows just say Cleveland for fun they got
two number ones first and what the 12th
pick and said we'll send you those two
and we'll send you terrelle pryor for
what I mean it's not gonna happen cause
they're gonna draft the defensive end
anyway with but if they did it if you're
the Houston Texas as much as JJ is is
Houston if you don't take that then we
ought to fire you and kick you out of
the league because you've got it you've
got to have that then you draft a court
if the Patriots called up them and said
how about Garoppolo and our number two
or one for JJ the experiment and yeah I
would draft a quarterback every year on
any and every round every year if I be
like in the third round one your fifth
round the next seventh round first round
because eventually you're gonna hit but
yes I can see a scenario because his
trade value was so high and like I said
if you give me an Aaron Rodgers or give
me if Garoppolo pans out you're gonna
win a deal look what happened to the
Texans this year as good as JJ is he's
out the whole year and they won the
division I think the development of
clowny and no question this is hinder
yeah makes him even more
it makes him even more dispensable and
you're saying that about a three-time
defensive MVP and a hall-of-famer yeah I
can see a scenario matter of fact I'll
be now telling that to McNair family and
the people in
Houston because he's such a figure here
but if you want to make your team better
and we all know look at the final eight
and the final four in the playoffs what
position must you have unless you have
the aberration of the two thousand
Ravens defense the 85 Bears defense you
must have the guy under Center who can
let it rip and make take ordinary and
make it extraordinary and those guys do
was Brock Osweiler mistake my emotion
because I know him I don't want you know
and you know me Dan I'm not much of a
fence that I like the guy but I watched
mechanics and you look at look at the
great players Matt Ryan the way he's
playing he told me a year ago at the
Super Bowl at this time last year if I
cut down my red zone interception as we
got a chance to be here playing next
year and he did and look at the result
but he worked at nauseam at his
mechanics Brady does the same thing
Brock's long and overextended and
sometimes you can just see he's never
gonna be a 63 percent completion guy
he's just not he's a big strong guy who
gets long and we have never had a 6/8
guy win a champion we just don't talk
quarterbacks like that when I say that
big we just we don't draft him and they
don't usually win I would love him to
succeed but Dan we've seen a body of
work for a year with this supposed
quarterback guru they with a great
defense they upgraded their offense in
the offseason and at times you wonder if
Brock could throw it in the ocean when
he's standing on the beach and
unfortunately when you're that you can't
take a guy who's a fifty-four percent
completion guy and make him a 62 hey you
can take a 60 and make him a 62 Brees
will throw for 70% with a blindfold on
so will Ryan silver Rodgers those guys
are accurate I I personally mistake yes
and Dan sometimes you just got a I'm
hoping that he competes and comes back
and works this offseason and gives them
something but that first impression we
got was game after game and what I saw
I'm looking for not just wins or or
touchdown passes did they get better did
he get better you tell me one game or
three quarters in a row or four quarters
that you looked him and said that's 72
million dollars worth that's a Super
Bowl quarterback it did not happen they
have to draft the quarterback again this
year and give Savage and another guy a
chance to compete sometimes you just got
to take the L man and say we spent money
we shouldn't have spent deshaun Watson
his resume you lead with the two games
against Alabama back-to-back years
and there are still gonna be people who
aren't gonna sign off on deshaun Watson
whether it's his style or you you know
whatever it might be right would you
sign off under Shawn Watson as the
number one quarterback
I would now I'm a true Biscay guy but
Dan I haven't seen enough body of work
from true Biscay you know he looks the
part you know when we look at Carson
Wentz looks the part big strong guy who
can rip it but true Biscay there's talk
that he's not six three six one and a
half and we've been playing yes
important game that's my point
and so when I watch watch and whenever
we hear the word dual threat quarterback
or the the phrase what do we think of
Dan oh great runner he couldn't throw up
yeah you know it's like Bill Jones yes
that's exactly right but Watson Dan my
favorite thing is when the temperature
of the game goes up guys like me us mere
mortals when the temperature of the game
goes up we throw up in our mouths when
those guys like Watson you just for the
record you never throw up on the field
catchers and backup quarterbacks make
for great Rizzo so then I I sign off on
him now because under the the brightest
lights in the biggest stage he's taking
what we call the greatest college coach
and the greatest college coaches
defenses and carved them up like he
owned him and he's done it and my
favorite thing about him was with this
past one he started off for the first
quarter in half and it looked like he
was gonna urinate down his leg and then
BAM came back out in the last three and
a half quarters and loaded a team up and
single hand we talked about defense wins
championships none and not in that game
well Clemson play well a dude and a
quarterback carried them and got them
through making every play necessary
I do sign off on him now I don't put him
in that you know when we had eight men
in luck and in Elway you knew John you
know what I'm saying
we knew that John was gonna be special
with the Shawn I think he can with the
proper putting the ball in his hand and
believing and turn it over to him but I
don't look at him as oh my gosh no
brainer but I signed off he's the best
quarterback in this draft and after his
performance under pressure if you don't
think that guy has ice in his veins and
you don't pass on him what we do is we
talk ourselves out of draft picks
between now and April they need to draft
guys if it's not the first pick it
better not be the fifth pick he can play
he's Sean Salisbury the new Sean
Salisbury show debut Super Bowl week on
SP nation radio and ESPN Radio Houston
host as well it's great to see if you're
watching on DirecTV the audience Channel
239 or the NBC Sports Network Sean is
going to throw footballs to McLovin
during the look in McLovin you got your
gloves I do are you gonna you know take
it easy on me are you gonna really let
it go I am gonna do you matter of fact
you got a is anybody that stands ready
to take McLovin place you'll be dead by
the time I get done with it if you guys
are gonna make me in street clothes and
having knee surgery two weeks ago throw
you better because I'm gonna let it rip
dude you better be ready it's all about
you might want to have contacts on
because those it's all about content
McLovin as long as it's on camera that's
alright well the key is I'm just gonna
come and work right there he's not gonna
break my glasses again I'm gonna save
you such nice touch I'm away the play of
the day is coming up next here on the
dam thanks Daniel give up the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]